翻訳:
校正: Hiroko Kawano
改めまして皆さん こんにちは
岸田ひろ実と申します
早速なんですけれども 皆さんに質問です
今 車椅子で私がここに上ってきました
皆さん 車椅子の私を見て
どのような印象を持たれるでしょうか
もしかしたら ああ 可哀想だな
もしかしたら 大変そうだな
もしかしたら 何かしてあげないと
いけないかな
そんな風に思われたのではないでしょうか
実は私 車椅子暦
今年でもうすぐ7年になります
ということは 7年前は
普通に歩いていました
歩いていたときの私も
きっとそういう風に思っていたと思います
可哀想だなとか 不幸せそうだなとか
マイナスのイメージがありました
しかし 今ここにいる私は 実は
今までの人生の中で
一番幸せだと思っています
歩いていたときよりも
今のほうが楽しいです
幸せです
夢もたくさんあります
希望もたくさんあります
毎日わくわくして生きています
それでは どうしてそんな風に
思えるようになったのか
私のアイデアを今から
お話していきたいと思います
実は なぜ私がこのように
車椅子の生活になったかといいますと
ちょうど7年前のある日 突然です
大動脈乖離という病気に襲われました
心臓から出る大きな血管が
裂けていく病気です
これが裂けきったら
もう即死という状態でした
緊急搬送された病院で宣告されたのは
9割の確率で命を落とすでしょう
ということでした
そして緊急オペに入りました
10時間のオペを経験した後 幸いにも
一命を取り留めることができました
そして 麻酔から覚めた私は
まったく足が動かなくなっていました
胸から下が麻痺をしてしまったんです
その日から私は
日常 普通にできていること 当たり前のこと
全てを失ってしまいました
絶望と向き合う日が始まってしまいました
私には家族がいます
写真に写っているように
長女と そしてダウン症という
知的障害のある長男と 3人家族です
夫は10年前に
病気で亡くなってしまいました
私にとって頼れる存在であるのは
たった一人の長女でした
そんな長女は 歩けなくなった私を
毎日毎日励ましてくれました
「ママ大丈夫だから」「なんとかなるから」
「一緒に頑張ろう」一生懸命励ましてくれました
しかし そんな励ましは
私にとって全く響かなかったです
心に届かなかったです
それはどうしてかと言うと
今まで普通に出来ていたことが
全く出来なくなったからです
例えば 寝返りを打つことも
一人では出来ません
ベッドから起き上がることも出来ません
もちろん
車椅子に乗り移ることも無理でした
お風呂も一人では無理
トイレも一人では無理
無理なことばっかりです
そんな私に「大丈夫だよ」と言われても
何が大丈夫なのと
毎日毎日ベッドで泣いていました
しかし 娘が来ると
娘にはこれ以上苦労をかけたくない
落ち込んでいる私の姿を見せたくない
という私の意地があったので
いつもいつも笑ってやり過ごしていました
「大丈夫大丈夫 私は大丈夫だよ」
そういう風にやり過ごしていました
しかしある日 大きな転機がやってきました
なんとなく自分で動けるようになってきた頃
病院から外出許可が出ました
娘は私に言いました
「ママ 三宮の街に行こう」
「歩いていたときと一緒のようにまた
三宮に買い物に行って
ご飯食べに行こうよ」
と言ってくれました
ああそっか
私もそういえば入院生活も長い
もう半年以上あったので 久しぶりに
外出できるととても嬉しかったです
たとえ車椅子でも
また前みたいに楽しめるかもしれない
そんな思いを持って
娘と2人で三宮の街に出かけました
少しわくわくしました
しかしそんな気持ちも
たったの1時間も経たないうちに
崩れ落ちていきました
いつもなら
ここからそこに行くのに数十秒です
しかしそこには
超えられない段差がありました
階段がありました
行けない どうやって行けるんだろう
誰も教えてくれませんでした
お手洗いに行きたい と言っても
普通のトイレには行けません
車椅子トイレどこにあるんだろう
探さないといけないです
いちいち 何をするにも大変です
そして混雑している道路を通るには
車椅子には幅があります
なので すいません ごめんなさい
通らせてください
謝ってばかりいました
そうして落ち込んだ気持ちを持ったまま
ようやくたどり着いた夕食のお店
パスタを食べようということで
パスタ屋さんに入りました
やっと入れるお店を見つけました
そうして そのお店 通路は狭かったです
ごめんなさい ごめんなさいと言いながら
やっと通らせてもらって
テーブルにつくことができました
そのときです
私の どうしようもない落ち込んだ気持ち
もう無理じゃん
車椅子でも大丈夫って言われたけど
結局車椅子ってこんなに外に出るのも
辛いことがいっぱいある もう無理だ
その気持ちは限界になっていました
そしてとうとう 娘に言ってしまいました
「もう なんで ママ生きているんだろう
もう死んだほうがマシだった
もう死にたい」
そんな風に言ってしまいました
私は娘の顔を見ることが 出来ませんでした
きっと泣いて
「ママ死なないで 何でそんなこと言うの」
と言うと思っていたんですね
恐る恐る娘の顔を覗いてみました
しまった… 言ってしまった…
と思いながらです
そうすると娘は
パスタをパクパク食べていました
そして私に言いました
「うん 知ってるよ
きっとそう思ってると思ってた
だから死にたいなら死んでもいいよ」
と言いました
「きっと死んだほうが楽なくらい
ママは苦労してるのを しんどいのを
知ってるから 死んでもいいよ
でも 私にとってママはママだから
歩いていても歩いてなくてもママはママで
変わらず私を支えてくれてるから
私にとったら何にも変わらない
だから大丈夫
大丈夫大丈夫
2億パーセント大丈夫だから」
と言ってくれました
言われた私のほうが
ビックリしてしまいました
えっ「 死んでもいい？」
そこは「死なないで」と言うところ
じゃないのかなと思ったんですが
「死んでもいい」という
選択肢を与えてもらったら
私は一体 何にこんなに落ち込んでるんだろう？
そして2億パーセント大丈夫というような
聞いたこともない大丈夫という確率に
「ああ じゃあ娘を一回信じてみよう」
と思いました
もう歩けてても歩けてなくても
どうでもいいやと思いました
そして娘に本当の気持ちを
話したということだけで
私はすごく気持ちが楽になりました
なんか歩けても歩けてなくても
生きてるだけで娘の役に立ってることが
あるかもしれない
そうすれば 私もこれから
また何かできるかもしれない
歩けないことばっかり悔やんでても
落ち込んでるばっかりでも何も楽しくない
そしたら 歩けなくてもできること
車椅子の私しかできないこと
何かないかな
そんなことを思い始めるようになりました
そうすると不思議です
なんだか外に出たくなります
なんかやってみようと思いました
そして 何とかリハビリ生活を乗り越えて
私は ある程度自分で動けるようになって
病院を退院することになりました
そうしているうちにも どんどんどんどん
外に出るようになりました
たくさんの人と知り合うようになりました
街へ出ると 今まで気づかなかったことに
たくさん気づくようになりました
どうしてここからそこへ行くのに
行けないのだろう？
どうしてこの物を使いたいのに
使えないのだろう？
そしたら 行けないところを
行けるようにしたらいいんじゃないか
使えない物を
使えるようにしたらいいんじゃないか
そんなこといつもいつも
考えるようになりました
そして私は今 障がいのある私の立場から
皆さんにユニバーサルマナーといって
実際に障がいのある方がいらした場合
その向き合い方・接し方について
お教えするお仕事をしています
私の障がいは
私に仕事を与えてくれました
障がい イコール マイナスでしかなかった
歩けない イコール 不幸でしかなかった
それが今
障がいはマイナスばかりではない
不幸ばっかりではない
そんな風に思えるようになりました
ひとつ 私が皆さんに普段お話している
ユニバーサルマナーについて
お話をさせてください
どんなことを伝えているか
またちょっとここで皆さん一緒に
考えてみてください
例えば私が食事をしに
レストランに行ったとします
そうすると お店の方は
車椅子の私に気がついて
「こちらへどうぞ」というように
テーブルの椅子を一つ外して
「こちらへどうぞ」と案内してくれます
さて皆さん これって
正しいおもてなしでしょうか
実は これは違うんですね
車椅子に乗っているからといって
車椅子のままお食事をする
それが正しい答えではないんです
私も ソファの種類によったり
その場所・椅子の種類によったりしては
車椅子から椅子に座りたいと
思うこともあります
車椅子にずっと座ってると
硬いですしリラックスできないので
椅子に座りたいということもあるんですね
ですので そういったときは何も聞かずに
車椅子だから椅子を抜こう ではなくって
まず選択肢を与えてください
その選択肢を与えるために
どうしたらいいですか？
何かお手伝いしましょうか？
という風にお声かけをしてください
そして本当にしてほしいこと
その方が何をしてほしいか
ということを聞いてください
これが正しいおもてなしなんですよ
ステキなおもてなしなんですよ
というようなことを
私は皆さんにお伝えするお仕事をしています
これって 実際私が車椅子に乗って
初めて分かったことです
私の車椅子に座っての
目線の高さは1メートルです
この1メートルの目線だから見えること
気づくこと たくさんあります
これは私でしか気づかない
私でしか伝えられないことだと
思っています
ですので 障がい イコール マイナス
不幸ではありません
障がいは私に価値を気づかせてくれます
私に夢を与えてくれます
そして仕事も与えてくれました
もし皆さんが落ち込んで
どうしようもないとき
どうしたらいいかわからない
もうだめだって思うとき
ぜひ みなさんの近くにいる
大切な方にひとこと言ってみてください
もう無理かもしれない
もうだめだ 死にたい
そんな気持ちをひとこと
話してみてください
もしかしたら その方は
何かアイデアをくれるかもしれません
もしかしたら うんうん そっかそっかと
聞いてくれてるだけかもしれません
でも その人に話せたということだけで
あなたの何かが変わります
だめだ もうだめだって思っている気持ちが
そうじゃない風に変わります
マイナスがプラスに変わるきっかけになります
ぜひ 皆さんも落ち込んだとき
そういうアイデアを一つ
覚えておいてください
私の障がいがくれたものにもう一つ
夢があります
夢を私に与えてくれました
その夢は 皆さんの前で
私の障がいをプラスに変えて価値に変えて
私でしか気づかないことを皆さんの前で
アイデアとしてたくさんお話する
ということが私の夢でした
そうして 今この場所で 私の夢は
まさに叶っています
こんなチャンスをいただきました
皆さんにたくさん聞いて頂いてます
本当に嬉しいです
本当に楽しい
今この スピーチの時間をいただきました
本当にありがとうございました
では ご静聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）